bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler d'isaac newton
newton est ainsi
fyk anglais né en 1642
figure incontournable de la science
moderne
on lui doit entre autres la fondation de
la mécanique classique
ainsi que la théorie de la gravitation
universelle
aux portes sur tous les domaines de la
science aussi bien la physique que
l'astronomie ou les mathématiques
mais ce qu'on ignore ou en tout cas ce
que le grand public c'est beaucoup moins
c'est que newton n'était pas seulement
versé dans les sciences
il voit également un immense intérêt à
la théologie
mais aussi et j'oserais dire
hier encore plus surprenante
j
cette discipline au culte
de nombreux récits légendaires ou
fantastique
lesquelles se mêlent magie easter et
sorcellerie
dont l'objet
l'arrêt et la création de la fameuse
pierre philosophale
une pierre supposément capable de
transformer le plomb en or
de guérir toutes les maladies
de prolonger indéfiniment la vie humaine
et ce qui mérite d'être souligné
e
éventuellement croire
intérêt de newton pour l'alchimie ne
relevait pas simplement du loisir
récréatif
man une manière de s'aérer les neurones
après une séance d'équations un peu trop
intensive
pour le dire clairement
on croyait dans l'alchimie
ils croyaient dans la possibilité de
réaliser la pierre philosophale
on considérait déjà largement l'alchimie
comme une fumisterie
tall était déjà bien installée
la raison scientifique s'était imposé
face aux superstitions
et la prétention à transformer le plomb
en or ou à accéder à l'immortalité
pouvait évidemment être perçue
comme une tentative d'exploiter la
crédulité des plus naïfs
or pour lui
nous
me net
fumisterie
elle était bel et bien
une réalité
il étudia pendant plus de trente ans
l'expérimenta dans son laboratoire
p de son fourneau
peut qu'être surpris lorsqu'on apprend
que sur la totalité des écrits de nous
donne
moins de 30% porte sur les sciences le
reste étant consacré à la théologie et à
l'alchimie
évidemment rétrospectivement
gênant
parce que la question qu'on se pose
c'est
un tel génie de la science
un esprit rationnel et rigoureux
s'appuie sur des calculs et des
démonstrations
at il pu donner du crédit à une
discipline
qui a moins les apparences de la science
celle de la science fiction
ce qui a échappé à newton
un penchant à l'irrationnel qui l'a
conduit à croire à la réalité de
l'alchimie
est-ce à nous
ap
la boîte des balivernes et des
pseudosciences
parce que cela ne cadre pas avec notre
représentation de la rationalité
plutôt que de creuser la question
tout simplement
rendre
terme
question qui vacances
m le fil conducteur de notre réflexion
c'est
qu'y at-il dans l'alchimie
newton a jugé suffisamment digne
d'intérêt
pour en faire l'un de ces objets de
recherche
m
tenter de répondre à cette question
j'ai fait appel à quelqu'un qui a étudié
le sujet en profondeur
avec qui nous allons tenter de percer
ce qui n'est pas excessif de nommer
mystère newton
frédéric mathieu est doctorant en
philosophie spécialiste de philosophie
des sciences
il est l'auteur d'une douzaine de livres
parmi lesquels l'annuaire de philosophie
des sciences
quand et la subjectivité
ou encore platon un regard sur l'egypte
frédéric sera donc mon partenaire de
réflexion sur la question de l'alchimie
chez newton
bonjour frédéric bonjour
maintenant est ce que tu pourrais
compléter cette présentation en nous
expliquant ce qui t'a amené à
t'intéresser à newton et en particulier
à newton l'alchimiste alors la réponse
n'est pas évident dans la mesure où
s'intéresser à newton lorsqu'on fait de
la philosophie ne coule pas de source
il faut savoir que à l'époque de newton
ce que nous nommons les scientifiques
s'intituler le même les philosophes de
la nature donc newton est un philosophe
de la nature par extension new town est
un philosophe au même titre que platon
socrate qui était à la fois des
philosophes des physiciens des
moralistes
ces distinctions n'avait pas encore
cours à l'époque donc il n'est pas
aberrant de s'intéresser à un philosophe
lorsque soi même on est philosophe
ensuite pourquoi newton alors je me suis
approché de la philosophie plus par
défaut que par réel choix parce que je
pensais que la philosophie me
permettrait de faire des synthèses entre
différentes branches de la connaissance
je pensais que la philosophie avait
cette qualité en fait de se pencher par
dessus les disciplines et de tirer des
généralités dont on pourra tirer dans un
ordre supérieur des enseignements pour
une vie pour l'existence etc
ça n'a pas tout à fait été ce que j'ai
vécu lorsque j'ai fait mes premières
études de philosophie néanmoins j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses à commencer
par des choses sur les origines de la
philosophie et qui dit origines de la
philosophie 10 plateaux c'est à dire que
pour nous de culture et d'éducation
occidentale au 21ème siècle
pensant que platon et le commencement de
la philosophie ce n'est pas tout à fait
exact platon n'était pas un initiateur
mais plus un passeur de tradition plus
ancienne et pas seulement de tradition
présocratiques platon a passé notamment
des traditions orphique et
pythagoricienne c'est à dire des cultes
à nice terre des cultes initiatique qui
n'étaient pas des cultes de la religion
officielle mais une religion nocturne
qui se passait en parallèle de la
religion officielle
c'était intéressant de voir que platon a
aussi séjourné trois ans à héliopolis
d'égypte et on a retiré un certain
nombre d'enseignements sur les doctrines
égyptiennes qui ont rapport avec l'art
avec la théorie des idées avec le
philosophe roi et tous ceux ci forment
ce qu'on appelle le commencement de la
philosophie qui en réalité n'est pas le
commencement de la philosophie mais la
transmission de quelque chose d'autre
la réinterprétation de quelque chose
d'autre platon n'est pas une origine
c'est une étape et j'ai retrouvé
exactement le phénomène avec une tonne
c'est à dire que newton au coeur de la
révolution scientifique qu'on dit être
l'architecte de la science moderne n'est
pas l'inventeur de quelque chose mais le
continuateur d'une tradition en tout cas
lui se vivait comme ça
newton ne pensais pas être celui qui
allait apporter une connaissance inédite
à l'humanité mais quelqu'un qui allez
redécouvrir et retrouver une sagesse que
les anciens avaient et que les modernes
avaient perdu tout simplement
c'est ça qu'on peut appeler la
révolution de tony n'en fait au sens
propre du terme
c'est un retour aux sources c'est un
retour aux anciens cette vision de
newton c'est pas la vision qu'on a
forcément et c'est celle qui m'a
intéressé donc je me suis rapproché des
textes de newton et quand je parle des
textes de newton je ne parle pas
seulement de ses oeuvres publiées je
parle aussi de ses manuscrits inédits
donc ces manuscrits alchimique et
théologique qu'on ne connaît que depuis
1936 d'ailleurs ce n'est que depuis 1936
ce que nous savons par des traces
écrites que newton s'intéresser à la
chimie et à la théologie qu'il en
faisait la majeure partie de son travail
on le sait parce que à cette époque a
été mis aux enchères une malle qui
renfermait ces manuscrits notamment
l'économiste kind qui a pris qu'ils
aient été dispersés qu'ils ont été
dispersés à essayer d'en racheter un
certain nombre qui l'a allégué à
cambridge dans les fonds cambridge et ce
sont ces manuscrits qui sont pour la
plupart édité sur internet auquel je
m'intéresse dans mon travail pour
justement voir quel est le lien entre
les travaux scientifiques de newton et
ses travaux elle chimiques dans quelle
mesure ils ont pu être une inspiration
une source etc
avant d'aller plus loin est ce que tu
pourrais pour les spectateurs
les auditeurs qui n'aurait absolument
aucune connaissance en la matière nous
expliquer ce qu'est l'alchimie et quand
l'alchimie est apparu alors qu'est-ce
que l'alchimie difficile de répondre
sans faire des simplifications un peu
coupable il n'y a pas réellement
d'unités d'ado
une historiens ne peut pas abonder dans
ce sens réellement en revanche il y à
des démunis des dénominateurs communs
c'est à dire qu'on a des critères on
peut avoir certains éléments qu'on va
retrouver chez les différents alchimiste
depuis l'époque de l'ausim jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'automne ces éléments ils sont
théoriques
ils ont trait au caractère pratique de
l'alchimie et enfin à la dimension
philosophique où on dira philosophale de
l'alfi donc je vais m'expliquer
l'élément théorique qui peut définir
l'alchimie c'est un certain nombre de
dogmes
on va dire plutôt deux postulats qui
sont partagées par les alchimistes
le premier c'est le plus connu c'est la
transmissibilité de la matière transmute
habilité simplement pour que tout le
monde comprenne bien un pouvoir de
transformer la matière c'est à dire de
la modifiés chimiquement
oui même si le terme chimique est un peu
anachronique on pourrait dire ça c'est à
dire on va transformer la substance la
nature de la matière très bien voilà on
va passer du plomb alors on va passer
d'un élément un autre élément faire
attention aux termes d'éléments aussi
qu'il ya plusieurs définitions
bref voilà donc la transmutation t de la
matière corrélé à ce premier postulat il
y à l'idée de matières universel est ce
que si la matière que se transmuter peut
se changer en un autre type de matière
c'est bien qu'il ya une unité foncière
de la matière une unité substantielle et
que ce sont les accidents parler comme
aristote qui vont varier mais en réalité
tout peut se changer en tout et le
troisième élément théorie du commun ou
doctrinaire commun ce serait ce que d
scola appel l'analogisme c'est à dire
une certaine vision de la nature qui
fait que des enseignements que l'on peut
tirer d'un certain règne comme le règne
animal vaudront pour le règne minéral
exemple on pourra dire que les métaux
ont une sexualité souffrez principe mal
actif le mercure et principes femelles
on pourra dire qu'il y a des dévoration
dans le règne minéral qui lie à des
décroissances des dépérissements qu'il y
a des ensemencements d'ailleurs le terme
de semences est employé dans dans l'ue
dans le registre m'étais métallique
qu'il a une végétation des minéraux dans
les entrailles de la terre donc il ya
même embryologie chtoniennes c'est à
dire qu'un embryon métallique se forment
au coeur des mines stonienne chronos
donc le sous sol les tréfonds et tous
ceux ci forment une certaine vision de
la nature ou finalement des phénomènes
que l'on va observer non seulement dans
certains règne vaudront dans d'autres
règne mais non seulement dans certaine
échelle vaudront pour des échelles
supérieur donc ça ça nous ramène au
thème hermétique de l'analogie entre le
microcosme le maquereau cause le reflet
du microcosme et du micro compte ce qui
est tant aux et comme ce qui est en bas
dit l'adage hermétique donc on a une
vision du monde qui ait une vision
analogique à base de correspondances
entre les différents domaines de réalité
on pourrait dire en l'occurrence la
matière et le vivant on aurait une unité
de la matière une unité du vivant et le
vivant se retrouverait dans la matière
la matière est vivante
la matière est vivante il faut
s'entendre sur cette question
la matière n'est pas vivante d'elle-même
le souci newton un des soucis newton
c'était de montrer justement que dieu
était indispensable à la création et que
sans dieu nul matière ne pourrait vivre
donc dû interagit avec la matière à
travers une interface qui est l'espace
on y viendra peut-être pour lui donner
son animation du reste indispensable à
la création ne peut pas dire que la
matière est vivante mais c'est comme si
elle l'était ces trois éléments ce sont
les éléments théoriques de la définition
de l'alchimie il ya aussi pour définir
l'alchimie son caractère pratique c'est
à dire que je ne conçois pas que
l'alchimie soit uniquement de la
spéculation pour moi pour désigner
quelque chose comme étant de l'alchimie
il faut que ça ait
des implications pratiques et c'est à
dire il faut qu'on travaille la matière
il faut que ce soit assorti d'un labeur
il faut qu'ils les opérations chimiques
en laboratoire dont ce caractère
pratique est important et il va
s'illustrer dans l'alchimie chrétienne
occidentale par notamment deux quêtes
qui sont celles de la pierre
philosophale et celle de l'élixir donc
la pierre philosophale qui est un
catalyseur qui permet de transmuter des
métaux qu'est ce que ça veut dire
transmuter des métaux en réalité ça veut
dire prendre un métal qui est imparfait
qui est immature ou malades et l'amener
accélérer sa croissance sont guéris
cement son mûrissement son
perfectionnement donc l'alchimiste va
imiter la nature mais en accéléré pour
conduire la création de son état malade
malingre et immature vers son état de
perfection reviendra peut-être sur cette
question et l'élixir en fait qui a
exactement les mêmes fonctions mais sur
les corps humain stérile soigne pas les
métaux il soigne les maladies soigne les
hommes donc ça c'était pour le caractère
phrase pratique qui est le deuxième
élément de la définition de l'alchimie
ya un trois éléments troisième élément
qui est peut-être le plus intéressant
qui est son caractère philosophale parce
que si l'alchimiste cherche à soigner à
régénérer la matière à purifier la
matière à la perfectionner c'est qu'il
vit dans un monde qui est imparfait il
vit dans un monde qui est déchu
lorsqu'on parle d'alchimie chrétienne on
accole pas ces deux mots au hasard c'est
parce que le mythe
originaire de l'alchimie chrétienne
c'est bien celui de la chute c'est à
dire qu'on vit dans un monde qui est
imparfait et la mission de l'alchimiste
sera analogue à celle du christ qui a
purifié les hommes du péché originel ce
sera de purifier la matière voilà donc
en ceci donc en cette volonté de
régénérer le monde purifier la matière
et finalement de restaurer cet état de
grâce d'avant la chute consiste le trois
éléments troisième élément pour moi
définitoire de ski et l'alchimie
alors évidemment il faut préciser que
restaurer la perfection de la matière
dans le contexte chrétien a pour
équivalent dans l'alchimie gréco
alexandrine revenir à l'âge d'or par
exemple c'est à dire qu'on a des mythes
qui sont assez similaires à ses
analogues de ce qu'on dit c'est pour ça
que je me permets de faire de l'alchimie
une sorte de réaction à cette conscience
de la perte d'un état d'un état parfait
finalement une espèce de nostalgie une
réaction pratique à une nostalgie les
orgies bon alors beaucoup de choses ont
été dites
je ne sais pas si on va pouvoir revenir
sur tout mais on va essayer ya une
question qui m'est venue quand tu nous
expliquer
l'arrière plan philosophique de
l'alchimie et notamment cette question
de la transmutation dit et de la matière
tu as un petit peu décrit le travail de
l'alchimiste qui est d'accélérer le
processus d'évolution naturelle des
métaux et quand j'entends ça j'ai beau
savoir que l'alchimie est reléguée au
rang des fadaises scientifiques sur le
papier en quoi ces problématiques
en quoi l'idée de faire évoluer un métal
très telle une hérésie scientifiques à
l'époque de newton la plupart des
savants peut même dire que la totalité
des savants était acquise à l'idée de
transmutation de transmit tabilité de la
matière c'est à dire qu'il n'avait rien
qui a empêché cette possibilité la
question qui se posait était de savoir
si les alchimistes était en capacité d'y
parvenir
ou pas donc il y avait quand même un
regard critique sur certains récits
transmutation on se demandait si ce
n'était pas de la supercherie et
d'ailleurs il ya des supercheries qui
ont été révélés est ce que il est en le
pouvoir de l'homme de faire ce que fait
la nature
c'était la question donc il y avait
possibilité théorique de la
transmutation mais c'était la
possibilité pratique de la transmutation
qui étaient laissées dans le doute
en revanche un peu après newton arrive
lavoisier qui lui va révolutionner la
chine livre le domaine de la chimie avec
un y puisque il n'y a pas de différence
entre la chine telle alchimie à l'époque
de newton et
qui va proposer une nouvelle
nomenclature des éléments chimiques qui
va poser qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'éléments qui sont irréductibles et qui
ne peuvent pas de fait se transmuter les
uns dans les autres
donc lorsque lavoisier fait sa
révolution chimiques en réalité il sonne
le glas datchy puisqu'il n'y a plus de
transmissibilité de la matière il n'a
plus de matières universel et c'est à ce
moment là puisque l'alchimie commencé
d'être relégué hors du champ
scientifique qu'on a mis en branle des
tentatives de sauvetage de l'alchimie et
comment on a fait ça en la transférant
dans le domaine spirituel
donc on a commencé à dire qu'en réalité
les adeptes ne parlait pas de la matière
qu'ils employaient des métaphores quand
il parlait de transmutation du plomb
dans que la réalité de la transmutation
elle était intérieur par exemple que
c'était larmes qui devait s'illuminer et
c'était l'homme qui devait mature et et
se rendre parfaite alors pour embrayer
là dessus est-ce qu'on pourrait donner
un aperçu de ce que nous donne à 10 dans
les sciences et qui pourrait avoir une
origine dans l'alchimie lilia je pense à
un continuum entre les travaux elle
chimiques et les travaux scientifiques
de newton je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre de notions qui ont germé dans
l'alchimie de newton celle que consulter
newton celle que pratique et newton qui
l'a ensuite transposé développer et
employés dans ses travaux scientifiques
qu'on connaît principalement les
principia quoi j'aimerais un premier
exemple avec la considération de la
nature comme êtres vivants donc ça parle
pas forcément lorsqu'on connaît les
clous tibia mais dans le traité sur la
végétation
il compare la terre un gros animal qui
respire et qui exhale une certaine
matière qui est de l'éther et qui
respire un air actifs et cette vision de
la nature non pas comme horloge mais
comme gros animal ou comme vg table on
utilise le terme de vg table avec un
sens beaucoup plus large je suis de la
végétation en fait c'est tout ce qui est
qui est douée de vie est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve aussi dans les principia
dans l'optique et dans d'autres traités
si on fait attention donc le monde n'est
pas animé par une seule force mécanique
il n'y a pas que des mouvements pare
chocs de particules il y a aussi une vie
qui organisent la matière et qui
s'explique par des esprits actifs qui
chez newton vont devenir des principes
actifs qui deviendront des forces des
forces d'attraction la force
gravitationnelle entre les corps massif
entre les corps massif et pas dans les
corps massif c'est pas les corps qui
exerce cette forme et c'est entre les
corses et interactions entre l'école et
la force de cohésion entre les petites
particules ce qu'il appelle les
attractions à courte portée ou la
fermentation qui est le troisième le
troisième lieu où les principes actifs
s'exerce
je me permets de poser une question
avant tuées termine son développement
est-ce qu'on aurait tort de voir dans la
théorie de la gravitation
une manière d'établir une correspondance
entre les phénomènes célestes et les
phénomènes terrestres
c'est à dire que la théorie de la
gravitation permet aussi bien
d'expliquer l'orbité des planètes que le
fait qu'une pomme nous tombe sur le coin
du nez
est ce que selon soir d'après tes
recherches newton était dans cette
démarche d'unification des deux mondes
oui alors c'est une question qui va
m'amener à parler d'un sujet qui me
tient à coeur qui est celui du rôle qu'a
joué l'hermétisme dans la révolution
scientifique pour ça il faut repartir de
l'état de la physique avant la
révolution scientifique elle était
largement appuyé sur aristote et sur
plutôt l'aimé pour l'astronomie
on était dans un monde qui était séparé
en deux au niveau de la lune un monde
sublunaire qui était un monde en proie
aux contingences finalement
il n'y avait pas vraiment de
mathématisation possible parce qu'on
était dans l'imparfait en été dans
l'humain est une sphère reçu presse et
l'est où n'existait que des mouvements
circulaires parfait les planètes étaient
supposément parfaite et leurs orbites
également circulaire toute la révolution
scientifique a consisté à résorber cette
fracture entre les deux mondes
donc on montrant non seulement et ça ça
a été galilée par exemple qu'il y avait
des tâches aussi dans le ciel que
d'autres astres pouvaient être des
centres que le ciel n'était pas parfait
qu'il n'y avait pas que des mouvements
circulaires kepler a montré que les
orbites des planètes de marsa commun à
commencer par celle de mars et est
elliptique qu'il n'y avait pas de se
faire cristalline qui a entraîné les
orbes comme le pensait à l'époque
puisque les comètes folie traverser les
dites orb et a montré que le monde d'en
bas était aussi mathématisée bhl voilà
donc il ya eu un échange en fait entre
le haut et le bas et les principaux
artisans de ces révolutions ont été
vains copernic avec l'héliocentrisme ils
vont de quoi est ce qu'il a proposé
l'héliocentrisme moment de la révélation
d'hermès trismégiste d'hercule copernic
avait lui fit sans fils 1 à traduire mes
strips légiste à la demande de com de
médicis avant même de traduire platon
pour ça que l'hermétisme est souvent
associé aux platonisme parce qu'ils y
sont ils ont été traduits redécouvert
ensemble disons dans l'hermétisme cas
traduit sans le corpus trismégiste le
pin entre le soleil est au centre de
l'univers et on a une religion solaire
et don copernic à valoriser
l'héliocentrisme au nom de cette
religion sauvayre et la dic le
chiffrement bruno est allé plus loin il
le faisait également y pensez être un
prophète de l'antique religion de la
prise qu'à sa bière comme newton plus
tard en disant enfin valorisant lui le
centrisme et d'autres choses et d'autres
choses à penser que copernic n'était pas
allé assez loin en fait dans sa reprise
de l'hermétisme l'idée que la pomme
tombe comme la lune qui est un peu le
symbole qu'on peut tirer des travaux
newtonien c'est simplement une
expression de l'adage hermétique ce qui
est en haut et comme ce qui est en bas
cercle hermétisme lui s'opposer
totalement à l'idée d'une physique
divisé en deux sphères l'hermétisme
penser le monde dans l'unité dans
l'unité du haut et du bas voilà et tous
ces auteurs la connaissait évidemment
l'hermétisme le platonisme et à mon avis
ce sont les deux forces majeures qui ont
collaboré dans la révolution
scientifique et dont on commence
vraiment à découvrir l'impact que ces 50
dernières années
on connaît surtout newton pour sa
conception de l'univers
sa conception de l'espace mais est ce
que tu pourrais aussi nous parler de sa
conception du temps oui alors c'est
intéressant la vision du temps que
développe newton déjà il ya un rapport
au passé qui est particulier mais qui
était le rapport que les anciens eux
mêmes avaient déjà au passé
serait-ce que par rapport aux égyptiens
en vogue dans la grèce antique tout
vient d'orient est une sorte de mystique
de lorient parce que c'est là d'où vient
la lumière donc les origines du monde
les civilisations les plus anciennes et
newton avait ce rapport aux anciens dont
il pensait ne faire que redécouvrir
comme s'il y avait une certaine boucle
de la connaissance qui se renouveler
donc ça c'est une vingtaine moigne âge
de son inscription dans une temporalité
cycliques mais qui est cyclique à
différents niveaux
c'est la temporalité cyclique de
l'alchimie qui est exprimé par la
circulation de la matière qui va prendre
les différents aspects pour revenir à
son état originel ce qui est symbolisé
par lou robot rock par exemple qui
s'inspire des rythmes biologiques des
rythmes saisonniers chez newton et on
voit ça dans les primes kia il ya aussi
une circulation d'une entité qu'on
appelle les terres qui n'est pas les
terres cartésien omniprésent mais qui
est rien et terre qui va s'exhaler des
comètes du soleil désastre et qui va
être attiré par la gravité jusqu'à la
terre qui va se concrétiser et qui va
renouveler la matière terrestre qui va
disséminer des semences et des principes
actifs qui vont activer la matière et la
terre elle-même qu'on me l'a dit tout à
l'heure à exhaler cet éther qui va
revenir vers le soleil vers les astres
et donc il ya une circulation aux
perpétuelles dans le système du monde
selon une vision organiciste pour
presque dire il ya aussi cette idée que
les comètes ont certes un cycle régulier
elles font un certain tour enfin un
certain nombre de fois le tour du
système solaire avant de revenir mais
dieu décide du moment où il valait
précipiter dans le soleil
il n'y a pas de contradiction entre la
régularité de certains phénomènes et le
fait que ce phénomène dépend de la
volonté de dieu ce n'est pas
contradictoire
il donne la nature peuvent être
dépendance de dieu mon dieu les
précipite dans le soleil pour nourrir le
soleil le soleil sera vive la chaleur
est telle que toute vie sur terre
disparaît l'eau s'évapore la comète
ressort du soleil aidant sa traînée elle
va dispenser un peu de cet éther et puis
évidemment des éléments tels que l'eau
et les principes actifs des semences
véritablement et la vie va reprendre sur
terre et ceci se produit un certain
nombre de fois donc il ya aussi une
vision cosmologique cycliques chez
newton qui est très intéressante à
étudier et qui pose un problème qui est
celui de la compatibilité avec le temps
linéaire chrétiens si on se situe dans
une vision chrétienne
on est dans une histoire événementielle
c'est à dire qu'il ya une chute il ya
une incarnation il ya une résurrection
il ya une fin des temps une apocalypse
et un règne millénaire de dieu et
l'histoire prend sens par rapport aux
évènements qui s'y produisent qui sont
comme des signes des manifestations de
dieu ce qui n'était pas le cas dans les
civilisations anciennes ou là on est
sous le paradigme de l'éternel retour
donc il ya une réalité divine originaire
et tout ce qui se produit n'est que la
répétition et n'a de sens que en tant
que c'est la répétition de ces mythes
primitif
c'est ce que développe notamment
héliades ma newton et plus rattachées à
cette mentalité là donc à cette idée
qu'on est dans le renouvellement dans le
cycle et dans le temps circulaire cette
vision là était celle notamment qui
avaient le midrash donc dans la dans
certains développements
de l'exégèse juive on a cette idée que
le commencement est un commencement et
qui en a eu d'autres
dieu a fait des créations la route
détruite et a recréé recréera par
ailleurs donc c'est très intéressant
d'étudier ce rapport au temps kevin
houston newton avait une vision de la
religion très hétérodoxes et qui aurait
été très mal vu à son époque il a réussi
à passer entre les mailles du filet à ne
pas faire de carrière ecclésiastique
il en a été sauvée il a beaucoup écrit
sur la chronologie des anciens royaumes
avec cette idée que l'origine donc été
cette révélation première connue
d'hermès trismégiste et de moïse qui
règle et a enseigné aux égyptiens et
qu'on devait retrouver cette religion
par épuration le terme de la
purification et de l'épuration est très
important chez newton si bien dans ses
travaux scientifiques alchimique que
théologique et qu'il fallait donc
renouer avec cette religion noé et
est-ce que ça on peut le rattacher
directement à l'alchimie cette idée de
cycle cette idée de répétition en quoi
est ce que cette vision du temps et des
cycles peut raisonner avec l'alchimie
elle raisonne par rapport à la
circulation de la matière elle raisonne
par rapport à la vision elle chimique du
monde puisque les alchimies pense le
monde sous le paradigme de la corniche
c'est à dire que dans le monde il y a
des évaporation
puis il ya des précipitations et il ya
une circulation entre le fixe et le
volatile le fils de volatiles et le fixe
et il y a des un esprit qui descendent
en la matière qui remonte vers le ciel
qui se charge en vertu et c'est donc là
il y aurait une autre instanciation
totalement alchimique pour le coût de
cette compréhension des cycles de la
nature
il y a deux manières de penser le
rapport à la nature
le rapport entre la nature et dieu tout
cas à l'époque de newton donc celle du
temple qui est plutôt une modalité
ancien de penser ce rapport et la
modalité du livre c'est à dire que dieu
a écrit deux livres c'est paracelse qui
est dit
les écritures et le livre de la nature
donc il s'agit de déchiffrer l'un et
l'autre et en déchiffrant le livre de la
nature on se rapproche de la
connaissance de dieu évidemment par
contre chez les alchimistes ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant et j'apprends ça comme ça
c'est que le rapport à la nature peut
être un rapport sublimer voit un rapport
érotique
ce n'est pas seulement comme le dit
bachelard que les alchimistes font des
projections libidinale sur leurs objets
machelart prétend que plus on passe de
temps à étudier quelque chose plus il ya
de chances qu'on y fasse des projections
qui misent inhalent quand on fait une
thèse on porte un petit par exemple
c'est plus élaboré que ça c'est un
rapport courtois que l'alchimiste voit
la nature alors pour toi ça veut pas
dire que l'on dit bonjour excusez moi le
rapport courtois c'est un rapport
d'amour courtois entre un chevalier et
sa dame c'est à dire entre un serviteur
est une déesse subi mais l'alchimiste
s'éprend de la nature de la vierge
alchimie qui est saddam inaccessible qui
lui adresse son mystère et qu'il ne peut
jamais totalement dévoilée mais tous le
désir de l'alchimiste et s'est exprimé
dans les textes même et de découvrir ses
voiles c'est à dire de le pénétrer ses
secrets il y a tout un lexique en fête
de l'amour de la cour de la
fréquentation puisque la fréquentation
est nécessaire qui caractérise à mon
avis le rapport qu'elle a le chimiste à
la nature et qui est un rapport très
différent de celui qui aura le
scientifique moderne à la nature à
partir de baconschi bacon est une
transition
la nature sera mise à la question c'est
à dire que l'on va vraiment expérimenté
on va la segmenter et la connaissance se
fera par découpage ce découpage les
atomes de l'anatomie et c'est hier qu'on
ne cherchera plus à lui faire la cour on
va lui rentrer dedans pour le coup et ça
c'est ça exprime une vision technicienne
où la nature n'est plus un être vivant
la nature n'est plus animée et à partir
de là on peut l'exploiter véritablement
et à mon avis on rentre dans un autre
paradigme civilisationnel
à partir de là pour moi le rapport de
l'alchimiste est la nature est un
rapport à la fois érotique à un rapport
balistique
alors je vais peut-être prolonger un
tout petit peu la question en te
demandant si le rapport qu'entretient à
l'alchimiste avec la nature n'est pas un
rapport dans lequel il doit faire en
sorte que la nature accepte de dévoiler
ses secrets
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que le
scientifique qui cherchent à perforer la
nature il le fait sans son consentement
il fait de manière parfois très brutal
est-ce que l'alchimiste ne chercherait
pas le consentement de la nature qu'elle
lui dévoile ses secrets qu'il s'en
montre digne et qu'en retour ils
s'engagent à ne pas répandre les secrets
de la nature et notamment auprès
d'hommes qui ne leur ont pas forcément
mérité ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la
nature ne se dévoilent jamais tout à
fait elle rit elle en garde en réserve
et c'est ce qui fait que l'alchimiste
continue de la poursuivre que cette
quête ne finit jamais finalement c'est à
dire c'est un désir qui se nourrit du
refus de l'absence c'est un teasing
perpétuelle le secret elle chimique peut
avoir plusieurs fonctions il peut avoir
une fonction organique c'est à dire
qu'il va discriminer entre ceux qui
méritent d'avoir accès aux arcanes de la
et ceux qui ne le méritent pas ceux qui
ont un coeur un pur ce qu'ils veulent
s'enrichir par exemple ceux qui ont des
mauvaises pensées qui ne sont pas
suffisamment pieux cette sélection va
s'opérer à travers le décryptage des
textes puisque si on n'est pas
suffisamment humble et persévérant on
n'arrivera pas à décrypter un texte et
chic
il faut c'est un labeur c'est une ascèse
faut vraiment s'y mettre
elle peut avoir une fonction initiatique
pour l'aspirant c'est à dire que elle va
en quelque sorte mettre à mort sa raison
un peu comme platon réduisez c'est les
prétendants à la philosophie à l'aporie
pour ensuite ou pas leur faire grâce
d'une révélation généralement une
révélation orphique un rêve ou une
hypothèse quelque chose qui renoue avec
les sagesses ancien de lorient souvent
chez platon ou les sagesses orfi kopitar
gorille sienne alors il la troisième
fonction n'est pas réellement une
fonction du secret elle chimiques mais
elle oblige à un fait repenser
l'utilisation du langage alchimique
c'est à dire que c'est le langage qui
contient le secret dans la mesure où
c'est lui qui est voilée qu'il faut
passer à travers le langage et au delà
du langage pour entendre les termes et
les véritables correspondant chimiques
et terminal chimique s'il en est elle
oblige à repenser ce rapport au langage
dans la mesure où le langage de
l'alchimie pourrait être le langage la
nature c'est un langage fait de
métamorphose en réalité la nature et
dynamique elle ne reste jamais au même
endroit elle peut être plusieurs choses
à la fois donc c'est un langage
alchimique au sens propre du terme
donc ne s'agirait pas de crypter les
textes mais simplement d'imiter la
nature jusque dans son langage moyenne
question que j'aimerais te poser
frédéric ce qu'est ce que newton
rechercher dans la chimie alors deux
choses je dirais
la première c'est à combattre l'athéisme
menaçant et notamment l'athéisme
colportées par le système de la nature
de descartes puisque selon newton des
cartes exclut dieu de sa création
puisque le monde conserve
perpétuellement la même quantité de
mouvement c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas
de nouveaux mouvements qui sont produits
n'ya pas non plus de départissant de
mouvements qui impliquerait que dieu
interviennent pour repondre ajouté il
n'y a pas de place pour dieu dans le
système de la nature de descartes
selon newton s'est pas tout à fait vrai
puisque des cartes soutient une théorie
de la création continue et on dit que
conserver s'est créé le monde et que
dieu conserve et donc créé le monde à
chaque instant et donc il a cherché dans
l'alchimie un moyen de réintroduire dieu
dans le système de la nature et il l'a
trouvée à travers les esprits actifs qui
sont les principes actifs qui sont
les forces il a cherché un moyen de
réinjecter dieu dans le système de la
nature et de montrer que sans dieu la
nature n'était pas viable n'était pas
possible
et là dessus il est assez ironique que
celui qui a prétendu avoir fait avoir
porté le système newtonien à son acné à
son pinacle c'était la place la place
qui selon la fameuse anecdote à napoléon
qui lui demandait quelle place ils
essaient à dieu dans son système du
monde répondait qu'il n'avait pas besoin
de cette hypothèse la place a prétendu
extrapolé faire culminer par faire la
mécanique de newton alors qu'il n'a fait
que l'enterrer c'est une trahison
terrible et la deuxième chose que newton
recherché selon moi dans l'alchimie et
c'est une hypothèse un peu plus
personnelle que je demande à personne de
partager c'est un sentiment de catharsis
donc je pense que à travers la
purification des métaux newton pratiquer
une forme d'ascèse ou d'exégèse
protestante parce qu'il est né a grandi
dans un milieu protestant qu'il était
très religieux il n'a jamais de de
contacts rapprochés avec les femmes il
était extrêmement sévère pour tout ce
qui concernait le relâchement des moeurs
je pense que newton était en hébreu et
obsessionnelle mais un stade
caractéristiques et que c'est ce qui lui
a permis de faire ce qu'il a fait parce
qu'il a étonné son esprit incessamment
occupés alors incessamment occupé aussi
pour ne pas penser à la chair et ça il
le dit et il s'est inspiré d'ailleurs de
ce qu'il a lu dans les moines à 7 qui
parlait justement des obsessions les
obsessions de l'absurde et haute tension
charnelle je pense qu'une bonne fuyez
ceci je ne je n'irai pas plus loin dans
le pourquoi et la purification et est
donc quelque chose de déterminant dans
sa pensée aussi bien dans sa pensée
religieuse puisqu'il s'agit des purées
la religion pour la ramener à sa pureté
primitive à sa pureté pristine d'épurer
aussi les textes alchimique parce qu'il
va tenter de les traduire dans un
langage chimiques opératoire est donc là
il ya une énorme épuration qui doit être
fait par rapport au langage
et purification alchimique évidemment de
la matière des métaux et de l'unm par
projection pour terminer cet entretien
frédéric je te proposera une dernière
question
est ce que tu penses que ce qu'on a dit
aujourd'hui sur newton serait plutôt de
nature à jeter une forme de discrédit
sur sa pensée scientifique ou au
contraire est-ce que ce serait de nature
à nous faire prendre au sérieux ce qu'il
a pu écrire sur l'alchimie alors je vais
pas donner une réponse qui ne serait
qu'un simple sentiment et je vais
peut-être me baser sur un modèle du
changement de scientifiques qui est
celui de kun avec cette idée que la
science avance par révolution et qu'il y
a toujours un moment où le paradigme
dominant étant faux et pris en photo et
où il faut avancer quand même et là les
inspirations doit pouvoir venir de
partout
le problème n'est pas d'aller chercher
des inspirations dans la religion dans
l'alchimie dans le tantrisme ou ou par
ailleurs le problème c'est dans suite
développé des programmes de recherche
qui vont permettre de vérifier ses
inspirations de voir si elle apporte
quelque chose si elles permettent de
nouvelles découvertes
si elles sont utilisables si elles sont
de bonnes pistes donc fondamentalement
il faut toujours laisser leur chance à
des idées novatrices
quelle que soit l'origine de ces idées
les grandes inventions l'humanité
partent souvent d'idées assez fantasque
il y à des inspirations qui peuvent
venir de partout et qui peuvent être
intéressantes simplement on ne peut pas
savoir avant l'écueil serait de juger
une chose avant de l'avoir connue à fond
et ça ça peut évidemment s'appliquer
comme un axiome philosophie de vie car
ne pas condamner quelque chose avant de
la voir explorer avant d'avoir vu
quelles étaient les conséquences et les
finalités et puis surtout embrasser la
pensée qui va nous apporter le plus de
stimulation qui donnera le plus de goût
à la vie qui rendra les choses les plus
intéressantes donc l'alchimie un bon
stimulant de la pensée scientifique
absolument les concepts elle chimiques
on l'a vu à travers les automnes ont
permis de développer un système du monde
qui a fonctionné jusqu'à einstein et
qu'on continue d'utiliser par ailleurs
alors évidemment sans rappeler les
racines alchimique merci frédéric
[Musique]